good afternoon
good afternoon uh and maybe good morning
for those who join us from uh
non-european time zone
I'm Vincent Garnier the director general
of the ftth council Europe
welcome to this webinar
um titled performance transform optimize
your fiber network with a digital twin
I can see that we still have quite a few
people uh in the process of joining so
maybe I'll post for 30 seconds before I
officially start the session just to
give you a few extra seconds to to our
participant to to join the call so bear
with me uh maybe yeah 20 seconds and we
will formally start in a very short
moment thank you
thank you
so I think you can we can start and once
again welcome on on this webinar this
session is sponsored by
um hexagon on a member of the ftth
council Europe
and if we move to the next slide I just
want to share with you a few words about
our organization we are a non-for-profit
association with a mission to promote
fiber Network full fiber Network as the
most sustainable and future proof
technology for Access Network we want
all businesses and citizens in Europe to
benefit from the quality and performance
of fiber Network we regroup more than
150 members some of them are operators
investors others like hexagon are
supplier of solutions
and we have a variety of activity
including these webinar series but not
only that we also communicate to policy
makers we we develop Market studies
report and have our annual conference
the next one taking place in Madrid on
18th of April
this series of webinar is available via
our website you can find the replay on
the website and since you subscribe to
um and you accepted this invitation you
will be forwarded uh future invitation
for our next webinar
just a few practical points concerning
this session we are recording the
session and as for as like for any other
session of the webinar series of the
ftth council Europe you can access the
replay the link will be sent to you
after the event
um we are not giving you the possibility
to ask verbally any question but please
use the question box in the uh in in in
in the the box which is offered to you
on the control panel you can ask
questions I very much encourage you to
to post this question I will address
them to our speaker at the end of the
call and even if we don't have the time
to address this question they will be
forwarded to our speaker and he will
address them after the session
so with that I would like to
um introduce you to the topic of today
it's clear that rolling out and
operating ftth network is complex and
requires the management of an enormous
amount of data about the infrastructure
so from that perspective physical
inventory of network is essential for
the quality of deployment but also time
and cost optimization of your network it
is important that the deployment phase
it is equally essential to maintain and
upgrade the network
as many industry managing a large
quantity of data the ftth industry has
seen a shift from paper to more digital
tools and now artificial intelligence
and machine learning as we will see in
this presentation are changing the
Paradigm and offering extraordinary
opportunity so I'm very pleased to
introduce you to Jean Francois alar is
director mea utilities and communication
at hexagon
will present the benefits of geospatial
physical Network inventory and then
explain how the latest technology are
transforming the management of Telecom
physical inventory
so with that Jean Francois the floor is
used and I wish you a very good session
to all of you
thank you Vincent and uh welcome uh
everybody so as a Vincent explained the
goal of today is going through uh first
uh going the the benefits of the of a
geospatial pni and now I I I will
explain that I will show through
pictures and explanation what it can do
why we can call it a digital twin uh why
is a single source of truths what you
can do without any papers or what other
paperless workflow that exists today but
the second part of the session will be
really what we can do beyond the classic
view imagine that you have already a
rich set of data
about your network but what can you do
today with the machine learning
artificial intelligence 3D data
augmented Trinity and also uh what you
can do and what and how you can enhance
your I.T infrastructure to support those
new uh models of data management
so let's go first for the benefits of a
geospatial dni so what is a pni the main
goal of a pni is really to to take the
physical data that you have in the
ground and to put it into a digital
system in a database so so it's easy
easy to understand but the pni itself
it's not only a tool looking animals
support your business workflows and the
business workflows that you have when
you build a network when you maintain a
network normally you are with four
classic steps the first step is before
going to the figure to prepare the work
so you have to Define uh what you want
to do where you want to do it you have
also to understand what is already
existing what's underground everything
so you prepare the work uh it's very
often it's about preparing documentation
for your partner your subcontractor that
will go to the fits once and this
information it really should be also
already stored in the in your DNA
and then you send people to the field
and those people will do the survey they
have a tablet for also mobile
applications they can with the GPS
system they can measure they can
identify the location of the new uh
asset eventually you also identify the
living units so take pictures of the
buildings identify the number of Windows
what whatever and this information is uh
very important to go to the next step
which is the detailed design this is
where you will design your network you
will notify what to build but really in
detail what kind of right what kind of
manhole uh the the physical uh length of
the the duct and so on and finally
you have to build it and so you send
people to the field that will use the
the detail design that you order to make
within your pni and which they will
build and of course afterwards
maintained or even modify the existing
Network and so this is what's
normally a geospatient pni today can
support okay we can help you to do
within your daily business
you've launched the first poll uh for
today which I hope everyone can see
um so I would definitely encourage you
to answer to the following question how
many of the following business workflows
are if you implemented in your company
and you can select several of them so
the first one is digitally prepare the
field activities mobile field survey
detailed design of the network or mobile
field maintenance and construction
follow-up
so I can see that you're already very
busy voting
um things are defining gradually but I
don't have a very clear Iraqi yet so
Iraqi yet so I will uh keep on
um
give I give you another maybe a 10 10 20
seconds to to vote
um half of participants have already
voted so I would definitely encourage
you to uh to use the the device to to
cast your vote
um
I think we we start to see some uh
Trends so uh in the interest of time I
will close the survey and bring that
um online so as you see in advance who
are digitally prepare the field
activities gets 57 mobile field survey
50 46 percent detailed design of the
network
73 so clear winner and at 43 we have the
last uh proposal mobile field
maintenance and construction follow-up
so I don't know if you have any comments
on that
oh that's very interesting uh I'm not
surprised I was expecting a bit more on
the the preparation of the feed
activities uh because of fights I know
this is a very often there are
departments where that are full digital
but apparently uh the the detailed
design and the priority so yeah the the
those numbers are classic and uh uh not
surprising so yeah very good okay so we
can transition to the next part of your
presentation thank you very much for
voting
so the the it's interesting and so let's
go now to um uh to do more details about
the pni and what it what it has and what
it has to be for first as I said uh in
the in the mind of all the people this
the P9 must be the single source of code
this is where you have all your uh asset
inventory and if we look to the details
of what it is today it's location based
yes so you have uh you know where it is
but what is very interesting today is
that it's mainly 2D and uh we can talk
about that but today is there are many
reasons of that very often historical
reason but also because designing into
the collecting data into the is fast
it's easy and maintenance it's easy as
well
what we see also in the pni more and
more often the pnis are able to support
multiple Technologies so so you have in
a single system you will find Fiber
correction even copper assets the pni is
a single suit of truth but not only in
the streets underground or IR network
but also inside the buildings it will
identify where you have your racks or
even what you have inside your racks
with Device which are cards which patch
panels and even going to the ports where
you connect the other fibers uh if you
will have all the device but also
combining infrastructure and active or
passive device so you will start from
the trench through the depths up to the
manhole the racks and so on so you will
have everything inside your your piano
and uh the pni will be used for the
detailed design as I said before but
also more and more it's about simulation
uh what we call long-term transaction
you will be able to to build multiple
construction Center your competitive
because of the the scenario to simulate
uh incidents and of course uh more and
more often it's about historization so
keeping track of the change within the
system being able to go back in time
what was the situations six months ago
or even based on the past change what
will be the utilization of my network in
the next six months so this is also the
one of the trend and one of the usage of
the of a modern P9 the second usage it's
obvious but it's interesting to to to
tell it is that the pni is a source of
all the documentation you uh you
generate for each recorder it's about
butterfly diagram single line diagram
splicing diagram bill of material you
know otdr reports and all kinds of
reports that you can extract from this
single source of Truth and that you can
privilege towards your partner or the
different departments in the company
uh a natural extension of the pni which
is the physical networking inventor is
to be the link to create a link to the
logical inventory and to do that uh the
physical uh inventory must expand a bit
to not only to the assets but also on
what kind of service you put on the
asset and that's why you will have in
the pni information about fiber links
about channels also services and
sometimes even the circuits that are
assigned to the services and more and
more information about the capacity and
the the the of the network and also uh
allocation which services are allocated
where so this is the kind of information
that you can find also in the in your
dni
of course uh you have two main business
workflows that are mainly mobile the
survey uh the construction and for that
you need tools and the the an extension
to the pni will be natural extension
will be an online tool a web solution
that will be able to on which you are
able to connect to to review and even
update information of the of the asset
you can search for some search analysis
you can review any fibrous set you can
do go inside the building you can go uh
underground review your information it
must be configurable and much more
important it has to work on any device
so your partner they established their
phones you can be even at the office
using a classic Windows terminal so it
has to work on any kind of device that's
why we say it's a responsive web design
the the last uh uh capability delegated
to the usage of the asset information is
uh uh outside when you go to the field
where you will do the uh the survey or
even uh make some analysis on your TDR
uh test in the field fully disconnected
it's it it's meaningful so this is
something we could you could use and so
very often you will see a mobile
application that can be connected to
Genesis device I mean GPS antennas and
so on so that you can locate yourself
you can locate new assets you can access
all the data offline inside outside
plans live streaming ports connection
works and device you can also take
pictures video that you can link to your
assets and eventually also connect otdr
and cyberplex Analysis so this is with
all those tools connecting to a single
source of Truth to your digital twin you
can manage all the business workflows
now with the last uh uh kind of tools
that you can also use on the top of the
pni on the BNI database are the
analytics and they are not very
technical the goal of the of those tools
are more about the smaller dashboarding
uh it's helping the management to uh to
take fast decision in an intuitive way
so by thematic Maps uh real-time
information about the world the
incidence the capacity of the network uh
guiding the the management to other the
the decisions where to expand where to
maintain where to to take actions in the
fields where to to invest definitely
what is very interesting and we'll do
those kinds of Dodge body that they can
combine multiple Dimensions but not only
uh the the alphanumeric and graphical
information but also the time so that
you can see information from the past
and also eventually identify what could
or would happen in in the in the future
so this is a big benefit of the
dashboard and here you have two two
examples of for example uh cable
saturation in specific zones easy to
read easy to identify where things could
happen and of course in combination with
The Incident Management reviewing the
zones where you have very often or
regularly incidents either helping you
to identify where maintenance work
should or or or should happen or are
necessary adminar or short term
so if we look to the benefit of a pni I
would say a geospatial P9 in a classic
way uh one of the benefits we see and
this is recognized even by our customers
but I think by the market is that it
will improve the design process because
you have a
single platform you don't have only the
design but you have seen you can
estimate uh the work you can monitor the
work you can close open and close your
work order you can eliminate all paper
copies it's a single source of Truth
everything is there the digital you can
standardize the design process and even
more uh as you can divide the design
process and and give it to specific
departments inside the company so you
can distribute the workloads in a very
efficient way the other big benefit in
the uh the the field activity process
that could be highly improved because uh
first the backlog time will be reduced
could be even eliminated so the backup
time is the the time between data
capture in the field and having this
information in your in your inventory
could be removed in the past everything
on paper so somebody in the field takes
paper copies or is writing on paper this
paper to go back to the office where
somebody is recopying so the the risk of
mistakes or wrong with copy is high so
the data quality is directly impacted so
if you can remove this type of recording
you directly automatically improve the
data quality and beside this uh there is
also a a
possibility to hire or to improve the
customer satisfaction so it's about
reducing or short shortening the
response time uh you have to watch your
customers so you can anticipate or TDR
for example you can directly identify
where you have to send the people so you
can be faster in reducing your
restaurant time in repairing or we can
retractive or less than reactive so this
means that the retention level of a
customer could only be higher so this is
the high benefit of the of a good uh pni
implemented in many departments inside
the company so it's no time to to go for
the second part
well thank you very much
um so I hope you you all see this second
poll you're now familiar with the
process uh you just vote uh on the on
the control panel so the question is is
your organization in your organization
how many departments either marketing
Field Services Etc benefit from the data
managed by your p i solution so first
answer is zero to three Department
from four to eight or even more than
eight which I guess would be nearly the
entire organization
um
I can see uh voting taking place
there are more differences between the
different between the answers than uh
for the last question and maybe I want
to take this opportunity to remind you
that besides voting you can also of
course also ask question to John
Francois using the question box in the
control panel we will be very happy to
address them at the end of the session
I think we we get some clarity so I I
will not wait any longer and I suggest
we we close the poll and share the
results it shows on Francois that the
majority
um has up to three departments involved
in data managed by pni solution and 28
small a big quarter
um
have between four and eight only a tiny
portion of nine percent declare that
more than eight departments are actually
concerned by the p i Solutions
does it reflect what you see with your
with your clients yeah but I was hoping
to have a bit more than uh between four
and eight honestly so it shows that and
this is uh what we see today and this is
still a big Focus for the the Telco
company so the focus is still uh on the
construction of the network so that this
is the major need we need to deploy the
network and that's why only few
departments inside the company are
concerned by the pni because it's the
focus is construction but I'm pretty
sure that uh having uh the single source
of truth that is a pni can be used by
all departments uh we mentioned
marketing for example uh the sales
department could be also supported by
this but I'm sure the trend will evolve
over time but it's uh it's interesting
that two times more are still between uh
zero and three than uh four and eight so
interesting and maybe that your
presentation will dramatically change
the thing in in this
so let's let's without waiting move to
the next part of your presentation and
don't don't forget to ask questions
thank you
thank you so that and uh this is a good
uh transition to the the second part of
the of this webinar so know what I want
to do is to to show you what could what
you can do to go beyond the classic view
and the classic view of the piano and
the trend is clear is that the classic
view is that this is a tool to just to
support my the construction and maybe
some maintenance of my network but you
can do much more and uh I really uh
believe that uh you can do much more
thanks to the latest technology that we
have to on the market today so uh I
think that even the new technology can
we can help you to enrich the data to
capture information faster in the field
and even achieve what we call a true
digital twin because currently uh pni
data we can call them digital training
in the sense that it's a it's a a real
copy of the asset that you have in the
field but we have to admit it still in
to the two Dimension uh you cannot bring
this information to the field and put
this in the 3D model it will it won't
work uh you don't have all the real the
complete uh view of what's happening in
the field you you see the Digital model
so I think we can go further and uh of
course uh one of the impact of using the
new technologies it's about uh
integrating much more data than you have
today so uh Is it feasible how can you
uh grow the size of your I.T
infrastructure or broader your point CPU
to support the to those requirements so
and we will go through uh do sports
during the
the decision now uh what I would like to
first introduce is uh artificial
intelligence and machine learning so uh
it's still the the beginning but uh
those those tools can already improve a
lot the way we capture information from
the field So currently uh the focus in
the uh artificial intelligence and
machine learning in the the Telco world
is based on the uh picture recognition
and understanding what what we see and
understanding what we see and what is
the quality of what we see on the
picture so we have already automation
the leading to identify the type of
assets the quality of the asset so do I
have a water in a manhole do I have uh
uh is a slack Loop uh normally uh welded
or do we have a crisscross inside the
the manhole and so what we do already uh
taking a lot of pictures and in batch uh
letting a machine identifying what is on
the picture and we can we have already a
good result so you can automate uh
recognition and automatically Mission up
to more than 80 percent depending on the
quality of the picture what you can do a
lot the next step and uh we are already
working on it not only us but it is
about
splicing content of arrive you take a
picture of your record automatically the
system will help you to convert what you
the content of the of the picture into a
digital version of this so it can fasten
the way you are taking information from
the field and make sure that the
information you have in your pni is
accurate it's not no recopy it's really
from machine to machine directly so the
benefits of uh Ai and machine learning
are really big today based on automation
of photographic asset type program
detection color everything and your goal
is that you have a better match between
the physical digital models
automatically okay again big direct gain
in a quality and very fast you can treat
also a large volume of information very
fast
the second aspects and uh of that is the
moving for two 3D and I know 3D is a
something that is a
all of you they like to see your 3D
pictures and uh they they they they
believe that what what they see for
example e on this screen uh takes a lot
of time it's very hard to to get into
into my model my model is only 2D so
what you see here on the video is a uh
uh GSM tower that has been fully
captured by uh uh uh by lidar system so
at the beginning it was a point cloud
and in a semi-atomic automatic way it
has been converted to Vector information
to to objects and each object has been
identified and then after that uh
attributes have been assigned to each of
the device but what you see is that now
you have a 3D model that you can click
on it you have objects you can start
working on it oh that's nice but it's
still a vector object so let's go for
the next version of that is that you
take a lighter uh on claw please you
take uh pictures on that and you do the
same process and so bottom line you get
you see the same kind of antenna in this
case you have a high definition uh
colors and you can even eventually also
identify the the issues you have uh
corrosion of the steel uh you have uh
some the the effects are on some device
you can measure distance you can do a
lot of a lot of stuff already in a
Intrigue so you see today and this is
this information has been captured
directly from the field entirely
injected into the model
the limitation of this is that uh it's
isolated you see you have one antenna
you have another one no idea about uh
what you can do with your existing data
and so that's why now you can use more
and more the lighter data raw data so
just coming from a drone so this is in
this case you see a rail track that has
been fully uh uh collected by by a drone
and what we are doing now in in this
video is fusing multiple sort of Point
Cloud but also fusing uh Vector
information so it's a point Cloud you
can make measurements but you can in the
same data you can integrate Vector
information you see in green you see uh
poles coming from the gis so on the js2.
and you have to write the data not
Intelligence coming in embedding the JS
information what you can do is even
bringing another source of foreign
clothes so it's a bridge that has been
built later on so you have two liner
Source you have the jss and on the jss
you can of course uh get uh attributes
and finally what you is the ultimate
goal is to take from all those
information or what you need to get a
full digital twin that is fully
vectorized and with only assets but in
this case it's about uh
Railways but it can be anything still
basic but but it's very interesting is
that all the data that we see here have
been fully automatically converted from
a point Cloud to uh assets so the way
you collect a very large volume of 3D
data coming from point Cloud into assets
today it's a the cost is very low it's
just mashing time and you have directly
a real digital twin of your of your
model
but it's also interesting to do once you
are working in 3D is to get to to
provide to your pni that information
because this is always what I hear from
from my customers yes we would like to
go to 3D but we spent years in uh
collecting data in the field but
everything is in 2D know that we want we
see we can collect accurately and easily
at a local 3D data from the field like
here you see you have a nice location
you can you have the buildings in 3D uh
Associated to pictures that have been
mapped on on the the phone Cloud what I
can do I can for example and you see
through the what we call the X review
what you see here on on the picture it's
a combination of three source of data
data so there is gas Telecom and water
pipes that we see by transparency none
of that none of them had a z value at
the origin so what we did we just
assigned a default Z value to all of
them just to add them on the ground
automatically combined with the 3D View
and what you can do is even dig so we
will dig a hole on this place just to
see the the assets that we have on this
location
normally it should happen now
yes and you see so we have a role now
and we can see in 3d all the assets well
they are not differentiated by the call
but it could be done but what is
interesting is that your 3D information
you can click on an asset and you get
information on the on this asset but
it's very strong here is that we are
combining different source of data not
coming from the same company so it's a
gas water and Telecom different
different companies we're just combining
the data on its own location and just
giving a defaulted value to all this
information so this is the way you can
combine existing 2D information give it
give it a defaults and value and put
this information in the Real Environment
giving you the ability to see directly
what the impact Works uh on this
location what is the impact of existing
uh or other networks so and and again
this is something you can do today and
this is uh it's a change of mindset so
this is not a dream this is something
that can be done day at very low cost
and increasing your efficiency in the
field by the factor that I can count
because the increases are very very high
so the the 3D uh uh the user 3D data if
I I have to conclude first it will uh
yes not to be afraid uh the data
acquisition is very easy so we have more
and more lighter sensors uh today we can
fly drone so you can take uh pictures
from from cars in 3D you get Point
clouds you can technically get textures
and uh it's easy to convert the the
point load into Vector information
uh just using the the 3D data even raw
data without no transformation uh helps
you to make directly measure so you can
measurements between objects and also
make scientific checks so you have a
telecom Towers you want to to see the
current state you can see directly
without converting them to specific
assets just check it's easy to do
and finally uh more and more easy to
integrate 2D and 2D data together on the
same platform on the screen navigate you
can impose a specific to exact and you
can even do simulation currently in 3D
so this is a real benefit and this is a
real move if we look to what we were
able to do five years ago and what we
can do today I think this is a complete
change so really a great great trend for
the trade
the the last uh 3D aspect and data
management that I would like to
highlight now is the the usage of
augmented Trinity and for me it's really
something that uh you can get a an easy
benefit from so augmented treaty uh it's
about putting your data so your physical
assets data digitally uh in uh in a view
that shows the Real review so this is on
we are on a tablet you see a street
taken through the the camera or the
tablet and on top of that you just add
Vector information coming from the pni
or in this case it's a water network but
it could be any kind of network the data
can be on this under the device or
online but the big Advantage is that you
see the data directly superimposed with
uh uh your uh with with the the the the
streets and again being the new
technologies allowed to on the Fly
compute the default that so that you see
it on the ground but much more now the
the Trends on augment agility are that
uh you can make some analysis imagine
that you make a naughty Dr Trace that
you identify the location of the of the
of the the the the the incidence that
you see the otdr marker on your screen
in augmented imagine as well that uh you
have to identify all the assets uh using
a specific service so you have the
service name you identify the service
and on your screen through augmented
reality you see the line in in red or in
green and you can directly see all the
assets that are impacted by specific
Services imagine as well that you can do
thematic maps about Innovative real time
you see the utilization the the spare uh
or the spare capacity you see the
reservations you see the recent repair
the parts repair so you are underground
you say
uh points showing you where the network
has been repaired in the past past
months or past years and also all the
past incidents this is what augmentation
will bring you don't have to dig in in
life you can make or in 3D without
having to collect any ladder information
you can do much more than than ever so
the efforts you have to do it is just to
invest in a specific tool but no need to
dig no no need to transfer the data
directly you go to the field with this
capacity so this is clearly a major
Trend uh that you can achieve with the
new uh Technologies but of course
so nice pictures nice videos but the
Contour part of that is that it means
that you need you need uh computation
capabilities you need this space because
just uh I'm sure most of you know it one
light lidar Flags uh it's about it's not
about gigabytes of data but we can we
will rapidly talk about terabytes of
data manipulate all the data in your
software will require more CPU so if you
want to go to move towards this of
course this means directly that the IIT
infrastructure that FBI will be uh
enhanced and one of the solution to do
that is that okay I can shift my my
infrastructure that is already on-prem
and move all this power into the cloud
so no no secret uh moving to the cloud
it's a trend uh we see if you if we look
at the the the flex array report of last
year you see the number so already 37 of
the businesses uh spent is bigger than
uh 12 million
dollar per year for 30 of the visit and
80 of the businesses are spending at
least more than one million uh per year
for each company so this is a trend and
uh uh the main reason for that first in
the uh is the cost why
if if you had to buy all the machines to
invest in all the CPUs to do just uh
Point growth treatment and so on of
course uh you will be advised the
somebody will tell you this is uh
externabyte of a hardware big CPUs and
what you will do you will by then press
a safety buffer because you need to have
security for the next five years if you
have the questions from the cloud it's
completely different because uh then you
will ask what is the average need and if
I have fixed then I will pay at that
time for the specific Peak so you will
invest in a completely different way so
it's because the the cost is mainly uh
driven by paper use better utilization
and uh flexibility versus a five years
uh capacity plan the other aspect is
also more is more technical is the way
uh you can scale up easily once you are
in the cloud because you have new
technologies like a microservices
containerization blah blah blah a lot of
technology is allowing you to to
increase the the performance of the
treatments you want to uh to to apply
just by uh copy pasting your your
applications and making them uh running
in parallel to have faster uh results so
also on operational aspects it's uh uh
it's uh you can on your side you can
more focus on Innovation and less on the
management and maintenance of your uh of
your hardware for you as a company as
you have less effort to spend on 19
infrastructure you can be faster on on
the market So the faster time to Market
and uh
also and last but not least what is very
interesting is that uh cloud computing
is greener so and this is a fact and we
are all looking for uh being uh uh to
come to the consumer to produce less CO2
and be going to the road with the
terrific we will go into Direction
automatically so they have a lot of
benefits to go to the club but now uh if
you want to go to the club because this
is a really uh
you have to think about that moving to
the cloud is very often you will ask
okay what is the best cloud uh company
the cloud vendor on which I can rely to
put all my systems and uh a trend that
we see today is that is what we call the
multi-cloud so instead of having one
platform for all your systems you can
have multiple platforms both posting
each of them specific a key application
with a very fast interconnections so all
the vendors now provide this kind of
interconnection and this bring you uh
some some benefit first uh it can it
brings you the ability to negotiate the
price and to have the best price of and
performance inflation of the key
capabilities you need for a specific
application you can go for the vendor
one for another two vendor two so and
it's a good choice secondly uh spreading
your uh your your application on
multiple vendors will prevent you for uh
from Global outages is if you have
everything on a single vendor there is
to have a big outage and it happened so
the risk zero does not exist so having
this your application or multiple
vendors will prevent you for from big
big Auto digits
um there is also one point and this is
very specific to to Europe you know with
the gdpr uh uh rules sometimes uh it's
interesting to have multiple multi-cloud
so that you can store the the for
example the the data with some privacy
sensitivity in specific uh location with
specific vendors offering a more uh
regulation or more protection on that
and other application with less uh
criticality into in other in another
platforms and uh finally for the global
companies having multi-cloths also open
doors more easily to a
conversional availability so
there is no uh solution but what's what
I what I just wanted to to to show you
today is that uh new technologies that
are there uh you can go to uh
AI machine learning 3D augmented reality
of course all of this has to be
sustained by also a reflection in in
your
architecture so I think now it's it's
time to go for the this third part
thank you and the you can read the
question please check mark the sectors
where you have Investments uh planned in
the next three years so we have four
options one is artificial intelligence
and machine learning two concerns 3D
data integration third is augmented
reality uh typo here and the last one is
move to a cloud slash multi-cloud
platform
one two three four
um
the audience is a busy voting
and would you be able to guess who's
going to be the winner
yeah I think cloud is the number one
and uh and then number two I I think it
would be ar or machine learning okay
well let's see if you're appreciant
and maybe having heard you the the
audience will will prove you wrong
purposely I don't know whether you're
gonna influence
maybe maybe uh our audience likes to
play a little bit with that but um I can
see that 50 of
[Music]
of the attendees have voted and that the
the situation is stabilizing so without
further Ado I will close the poll and
share the result with you
um I think you were not too far away but
uh not exactly there artificial
intelligence and machine learning 42 but
the first one is move to the cloud and
multi-cloud platform and then at the
secondary level we really we have 3D
data integration and augmented reality
yeah
yeah I'm not surprised I'm not surprised
so it's in line with the the previous
portal and it shows really the the
situation of the market correctly so the
focus is really good the construction of
the network and machine learning and
artificial today can help to fasten
because
the market must grow rapidly but deliver
and deploy rapidly so it's okay and the
cloud multi-cloud it's a global Trend
totally intellectuals yeah
okay so maybe let's move to to your last
slide
it's about question and answer it's
about question and answer so I guess
it's a it's my time also to um to manage
that we we have received a few questions
so uh let me start with uh this one from
nazim
um I read it how do your customer
benefit from the AI image recognition
module
do you have figures that would help to
understand the benefit they get from
using this module of your software
yeah I I I I don't have figures that I
have a specific experience on that uh so
the the AI is uh not really used in in
Europe uh but we I know what
particulated it has been used once so
it's mainly used in other countries uh
Asia park or in Africa where they they
build the network without any uh digital
information store and know that they're
investigating in a physical Network
inventory they need to make digitization
and the only way to go fast and the very
low cost is to use AI machine and the
picture you you have seen were taken in
India to give you an example so what
they do they send people in the field
taking pictures uh the pictures are
located so you have a GPS coordinates
each picture and the sense of the
picture we can design and generate the
information directly in the physical
Network inventory so it's a unbeatable
in terms of cost and speed you can
imagine on the in a country like India
it's so it's so huge if you have to send
teams that will with even with a a field
survey too with GPS and will just Mark
say it's a manhole this type and then go
to the next next box and identify so we
do it automatically so in Portugal I
know that we did the exercise it uh the
the time estimated to make the manual uh
recovery was three months it has been
reduced to one month so just three times
faster with the same number of people
but three times faster it's uh already
give you a good
the goodest estimation okay
and
um I've got another question from
guillerme
um how important is the functionality of
accessing high definition street level
imagery
and lidar I hope I promised it correctly
when Planning and Building the design
a very good question
I don't want to promote too much uh eggs
and gone but what we see uh uh so we
have a program called hccr for example
we we can fly ourselves and generate
ourselves 3D and 2D data and this is
also a trend so you have more and more
because uh having the digital
information uh I mean like the data uh
on everywhere is true in Europe in
Europe many countries are investing a
lot of money in Belgium we are we have a
very good uh coverage for uh of all from
3D information in like that with a very
high accuracy in France it's coming as
well so in many many countries we see
here we see that but in a lot of
countries unfortunately it does not
exist if you go in Africa everywhere
even in the in uh on on the North so I
mean Tunisia Egypt and so on very few
information so what we do we flight or
we find Partners who are flying and
flying is less expensive than before
because today you can try with drones
with a good lighter sensor and so you
collect the data yourself and on the
location that are interesting you
because uh a normal fly uh flight will
be on all the regions but you can fly
only where you know you have to build
and so this is the way you get accurate
and the low cost between brackets uh 3D
data uh for your for yourself and for
your specific needs okay now I can see
uh questions coming fast uh so you could
have a short answer because they are now
piling on the list uh Calvin is asking
me are GIS platform in general able to
display 3D data and the network asset
records simultaneously at this time or
is it part of future capabilities oh no
it exists so we have it or other
companies are doing it so yeah uh I I
would say it's a it's starting but we
have the solution so we can do it for
more than three years and others can do
it also I think since three years it's
growing fast and the combining 2D and 2D
data in a single solution it's something
that is not yet common that will become
common in the next lecture but it exists
already okay excellent
how can you generate otdr Report with
the application and another question uh
does it have a library of products to
place while doing the design
yeah so otdr so I would say it's it's
it's once you have a pni so normally
well at least what what we do you have
all the the connectivity all the lengths
inside outside on facade and so on and
once and and once you have uh all the
links and you know which service it is
associated with specific time you start
from a port you the otdr device will
tell you that there is an incident at
for example 233 meter I wish to say to
the the pni system offline or at the
office for example or in the web
starting from here show me a marker at
250 meters starting from this part we do
if we you can even do more uh uh what is
also possible if you have all the
information you'll be like for example
the losses every uh splicing you can
also identify replace a marker where the
loss the cumulated loss is above 0.1 uh
millivolt DB for example this is what
what we can do and this is a feasible
today we have many many customers in
using it
is a question sorry so the follow-up
question is does it have a library of
product to place while doing the design
yes exactly yeah so you have libraries
and uh yeah they are okay and and a
follow-up of the follow-up the the same
person asking three questions in a row
uh does it generate underground networks
design like duct
um bank system or handhold and
yeah yeah of course so as I said at the
beginning you have to manage in your pni
not only the the the active assets I
mean cable fiber node you need to manage
the transit the the inner Dives the
branch enclosures all all the the device
to have the hardware that's just that
that sustains the the the construction
and the function of the of the network
yes
everything and even more it's always
interesting also to have uh the
surrounding objects the buildings but
also sometimes uh what we have in the
streets uh so always interesting to have
them as well in your pni
and maybe I have a question on my side
uh you touch upon it at several point
during your presentation and reacting to
the polls but what is your view on the
the General State of
um maturity of of the European market
when it comes to Telecom physical
inventory practices and Technologies
oh I I think the the but what we call
the T1 so the big Telco uh providers the
the they have invested for a while I
think since 2010 2015 something like
that they have invested a lot in those
Solutions so there is maturity but they
are they are big and they have to to
deploy large networks and they are still
uh very hardly building the networks
this is the main focus what we see on
the medium-sized in the small size or
even the newcomers on the market because
5G you know is also a combination of
fiber and a wireless communication so we
have new players and those those
companies are very small and when I say
they start very small they are still
using a lot of paper or multiple
solution instead of one pni they will
use a Visio for the the splicing they
will use Excel for the service name they
will use a GIS to to show everything and
as long as they are small it's okay one
guy can manage everything but if you
grow then you rapidly you are facing
issues and then those companies have to
migrate on what they have into a PNR and
sometimes I would say even very often
it's a double word because the the
technical choice they they took at the
beginning are so low costs and so
complex to migrate that they have to we
we do and uh and retype all the
information so it depends on on the
sizing but no as I said focus is clearly
uh to build all the poles are going in
this direction so it's really focused
going fast and uh and design it so you
see do you think the the maturity will
as as Europe and especially when it
comes to to fiber Network you know we
pass 50 of coverage so some some country
are moving fast towards uh 70 80 percent
of coverage so uh we go we go beyond the
phase of of for intensive rollout
um do you think that it would lead
operator uh towards uh considering these
technology with more uh intensity and
what could be the you know the what
could be slowing down uh operator from
adopting these new technologies these
disruptive Technologies
I I think uh yeah what we thought what
you say is exact so know that we're part
of 50 uh uh deployment in many many
countries in Europe it's it's though
they are starting thinking about going
uh in different different direction what
we see uh uh also is the the cost of
getting uh 3D information uh decreased
uh
drastically in the past five years and
it was a really a a limitation so I
think many many companies were already
asking about 3D capabilities five years
ago
or investigating and the technology-wise
it was complex
data wise it was very expensive
collecting data and also uh you know the
in the Telecom business it's good to
have a pni but what is costly is that
you have to maintain it because the the
once you build your network the next
step is to maintain it and maintaining
means extensions change and so on so
this means that the piano is not a goal
as such you have to maintain the data
and when it's only 2D it's easy to
maintain replacing or adding a new dirt
in the trench or change putting a new
manhole and so on into the I would say
fingers in the nose it's not complex
once you are you are managing 3D data uh
managing the network it's much more
complex costly uh so in some and five
years ago there was no solution for that
even updating Point clouds of specific
uh zones it was not there today we see
solutions from that coming so I think
the technical technology wise the the
solution exists price one is the the
price really decreased no the the break
will maybe be the mindset so you know
it's working very nicely very fine today
why do I need to change it's all about
change management yeah but and if you
were to if you were to to to select one
of these uh new technology that you
would recommend operators start with uh
if they if they were to to go step by
step uh you know transitioning from the
very basic solution you described to a
solution which really helped them grow
uh in an effective way
um what would you what would you advise
them to do and to start with
yeah only one so I think that the polar
as it did that if I go moving to the
clouds so it's more I.T choice and I
think cyber security and so on are
really good reasons to move to also cost
the second one honestly I think
augmented Trinity uh is they have to
look to look on that because it's a very
low value investment because it's just
using the existing data but what you can
do in the fields with this technology is
amazing you you have really access to uh
to your data in the real world so it's
really like uh you you see can you
imagine you designed a line at the
office and you go to the to the field
and you see the fight on the ground and
if you like it it's it's there you don't
have to dig and you see directly the
information and you can see as I said
otdr marker you can make thematic Maps
so I would go for augmented ready
because it's a very low low cost
investment with a very high return uh
very rapid so it is easy to use so this
is the way you really benefit from your
pni data at a very low cost okay
I think we're getting to the top of the
hour
um which concludes this um I think very
very insightful uh presentation I would
like to thank the audience for their
participation for their question I would
like also to invite you to to keep on
attending uh our webinar series and and
hopefully join us also in Madrid on the
18th of April to to meet the entire
community at the ftth conference maybe
you will have the chance to meet Jean
Francois alar and he is and maybe he's
digital twin as well uh will be there
thanks again very much for for attending
this webinar
um if you want to follow up with a
question just send it directly to the
ftta council Europe who will forward
that to jean-francois and I wish you a
very good rest of your day thank you
thank you all bye-bye
foreign